This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When you go to a concert, you might try to get there right when the doors open. Or maybe you take your time and skip the opening act. But generally, you want to be there when the show starts. In February, everyone who went to a concert in Haberstadt, Germany showed up 23 years late. Alright. Getting ready to head to the train station. One of those late comers was Gabe Bullard. Gabe's a reporter living in Basel, Switzerland.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当你去听音乐会时，你可能会试着在门刚开的时候就赶到。或者你可能会慢条斯理，错过开场暖场表演。但总的来说，你希望在演出开始时人在现场。今年二月，所有去德国哈尔贝施塔特听音乐会的人，都迟到了整整 23 年。好吧。准备前往火车站。其中一位迟到者是加布·布拉德。加布是一名住在瑞士巴塞尔的记者。
So he took the train a few hours into Germany to a pretty rural part of the country. Next stop, Alberstadt. Alberstadt is an old medieval town, like what you'd expect from a storybook. There are timber-frame houses packed close together, curving cobblestone streets. But there wasn't time for sightseeing. The concert was well underway. And Gabe was planning to leave early, because from this concert, everyone walks out early.
于是他坐了几个小时的火车进入德国，来到了一个相当乡村的地区。下一站，哈尔贝施塔特。哈尔贝施塔特是一座中世纪古镇，就像你从童话书里想象的那样。那里有紧密排列的木构房屋，以及弯曲的鹅卵石街道。但没有时间去观光了。音乐会已经在进行中了。而且加布打算提前离开，因为这场音乐会，所有人都会提前退场。
It's a performance of a piece called Organ 2 ASLSP. ASLSP stands for As Slow As Possible, which is how the composer meant for it to be played. And that's how it is being played. Very slowly. And the reason I came all the way to Halberstadt now is because this was no ordinary day of the performance. I came to see a chord change. The last time Organ 2 ASLSP had a chord change was 2022, and this new chord will play until the next change in August of 2026. There's a change the
这是一场名为《管风琴 2/ASLSP》的作品的演出。ASLSP 代表“尽可能慢”，这也是作曲家希望它的演奏方式。事实也确实如此。非常缓慢。而我大老远跑到哈尔贝施塔特的原因是，今天可不是普通的一天演出。我是来看和弦转换的。《管风琴 2/ASLSP》上一次和弦转换是在 2022 年，这个新和弦将一直持续演奏到 2026 年 8 月的下一次转换。之后的那一年
year after that and the year after that and so on until the year 2640. The full performance is meant to last 639 years. Walking up to the concert, looks like this is it. Gonna walk in. ["The Church of a Nun's Cloister"] The performance is in the Church of a Nun's Cloister, founded in the 13th century. It's an old building, with bare stone walls, a floor that's mostly gravel, and a wood roof. When I went in, there were a few people looking at what I realized was the organ.
还有再后一年，以此类推，直到 2640 年。完整的演出预计持续 639 年。走到音乐会现场，看起来就是这里了。准备走进去。[《修女修道院教堂》] 演出地点在布尔卡迪修女修道院教堂，建于 13 世纪。这是一座古老的建筑，有着光秃秃的石墙，地面主要是砾石，还有木制屋顶。我进去的时候，有几个人正在看我后来意识到是管风琴的东西。
But it didn't look like a typical organ. In the middle of the room here, there's a wooden structure with two kind of towers and then some metal pipes coming out of it. And they are making the sound. Those pipes are making the sound that's filling this room. One sound. And that's filling this room. One sound. And that's it. That's the performance. Well, at least until the chord change. At which point the organ will play a different one sound. Over the last 23 years, this tiny pipe organ playing this loud drone has drawn in thousands of fans, especially during chord changes.
但它看起来不像是典型的管风琴。房间正中间这里，有一个木制结构，带两个类似塔楼的东西，然后有一些金属管伸出来。它们正在发出声音。那些管子发出的声音充满了整个房间。只有一个声音。而且填满了这个房间。只有一个声音。就是这样。这就是演出。好吧，至少在和弦转换之前是这样。届时管风琴会演奏另一个单一的声音。在过去的 23 年里，这台演奏着响亮持续音的小型管风琴吸引了成千上万的乐迷，特别是在和弦转换期间。
And as unassuming and discordant as it is, it tends to keep people drawn in once they hear it. There are people who come for every change, often traveling from thousands of miles away. People who will stay in the church all day, just listening. People whom Oregon 2 ASLSP literally brings to tears. I came to Halberstadt to find out why. As in, why does Oregon 2 ASLSP even exist in the first place? And what is it that so mesmerizes people
尽管它毫不起眼且有些刺耳，但人们一旦听到，往往会被它深深吸引。有些人每次转换都会来，通常是从数千英里外赶来。有些人会整天待在教堂里，只是静静聆听。还有人听了《管风琴 2/ASLSP》后甚至感动落泪。我来到哈尔贝施塔特就是为了弄清原因。也就是说，《管风琴 2/ASLSP》当初为什么会存在？究竟是什么让人们如此着迷于
about being in a cold, crumbling building listening to this? ["The Last Supper"] building, listening to this. The artist behind this very, very slow performance was John Cage. Cage was an American composer who started his career in the 1930s with well-received instrumental compositions like In a Landscape from 1948. Cage's compositions could be complex and modern, but they didn't always push boundaries. That changed in the 1950s, when he began experimenting not with the sound of music, but with the idea of music. His most famous piece is probably 4 minutes 33 seconds, during which the performer is
在一个寒冷、斑驳的建筑里听这个？[《最后的晚餐》] 建筑里听这个。这场极其、极其缓慢的表演背后的艺术家是约翰·凯奇。凯奇是一位美国作曲家，他的职业生涯始于 20 世纪 30 年代，创作了一些广受好评的器乐作品，比如 1948 年的《在风景中》。凯奇的作品可能很复杂且具有现代感，但它们并不总是突破界限。这种情况在 50 年代发生了变化，当时他开始尝试的不是音乐的声音，而是音乐的概念。他最著名的作品可能是《4 分 33 秒》，在表演期间，演奏者
supposed to sit silent for 4 minutes and 33 seconds while the audience listens to whatever sounds are in the room, the air conditioner humming, other people shuffling uncomfortably, the traffic passing by outside. I love the activity of sound. Here he is talking about it in 1991. If you listen to Beethoven or to Mozart, you see that they're always the same. But if you listen to traffic, you see it's always different. You can read all sorts of meaning into Cage's work.
应该静坐 4 分 33 秒，而听众则聆听房间里的任何声音：空调的嗡嗡声、其他人不安的挪动声、外面驶过的交通声。我热爱声音的活动。这里是他在 1991 年谈论它。如果你听贝多芬或莫扎特，你会发现它们总是相同的。但如果你听交通噪音，你会发现它总是不同的。你可以在凯奇的作品中解读出各种各样的含义。
It's supposed to make us think about silence or randomness. Or maybe it's not really supposed to make us think much at all. In an interview, Cage quoted the philosopher Immanuel Kant. There are two things that don't have to mean anything. One is music and the other is laughter. Don't have to mean anything that is in order to give us very deep pleasure. In 1985, Cage experimented with time and wrote the first iteration of ASLSP with the explicit instruction to try to play it as slowly as possible.
它本意是让我们思考寂静或随机性。或者也许它根本不需要让我们想太多。在一次采访中，凯奇引用了哲学家伊曼纽尔·康德的话。有两样东西是不需要有任何含义的。一个是音乐，另一个是笑声。不需要有任何含义，也就是说，它们是为了给我们带来极深的愉悦。1985 年，凯奇对时间进行了实验，写出了《ASLSP》的第一个版本，并明确指示要尽量慢地演奏它。
Here's one of the early attempts. Now, if you're thinking that the letters ASLSP don't really correspond to the words as slow as possible, Cage is one step ahead of you. The title is also a reference to a line in James Joyce's novel Finnegan's Wake. The line is, Soft morning city, Lisp, where Lisp is just spelled L-S-P. What that has to do with the music isn't really clear. But as more musicians began to take an interest in ASLSP, very soon performers trying to follow Cage's instructions hit a wall. Cage wrote this first iteration to be performed on piano, but there's a physical limit to how long a note can sound on a piano. You press a key, a hammer strikes a string, but the string will eventually stop vibrating.
这是早期的一次尝试。现在，如果你认为字母 ASLSP 和“As Slow As Possible（尽可能慢）”这几个词并不完全对应，那凯奇比你领先了一步。这个标题也是对詹姆斯·乔伊斯的小说《芬尼根的守灵夜》中一句台词的致敬。那句台词是：温柔的清晨之城，口齿不清（Soft morning city, Lisp），这里的 Lisp 只是拼写为 L-S-P。这和音乐有什么关系其实并不清楚。但随着越来越多的音乐家开始对《ASLSP》产生兴趣，很快，试图遵循凯奇指示的演奏者们就遇到了瓶颈。凯奇将这首初版作品写成由钢琴演奏，但钢琴上一个音符能响多久是有物理极限的。你按下琴键，琴锤敲击琴弦，但琴弦最终会停止振动。
So the first performances of ASLSP lasted between 10 and 20 minutes, which is pretty long for a song. Just not, you know, long, long. Performers were stymied. They wanted a way to play ASLSP slower, much slower than was possible on a piano. But then, in 1987, Cage reworked the music for an instrument that didn't have any such limitations. That's Klaus Ad Heinrich playing. He's on the board of trustees for the project that brought Cage's ASLSP to Halberstadt. And he's director of music for the Halberstadt Cathedral, whose organ you're hearing. It's across town from the Cage project, and it's where I went to understand why the pipe organ
所以《ASLSP》的早期演出持续了 10 到 20 分钟，对于一首歌来说这已经挺长的了。只不过，你知道的，算不上真正意义上的长。演奏者们陷入了困境。他们想要一种以更慢的方式演奏《ASLSP》的方法，比在钢琴上可能的速度慢得多。但在 1987 年，凯奇为一件没有任何此类限制的乐器重新编排了这首音乐。那是克劳斯·阿德·海因里希在演奏。他是将凯奇的《ASLSP》带到哈尔贝施塔特的项目的理事会成员。他还是哈尔贝施塔特大教堂的音乐总监，你现在听到的就是该教堂的管风琴。它位于凯奇项目所在城镇的另一端，我去那里是为了弄清楚为什么管风琴
is the perfect instrument for a performance that needs to last a very long time. The cathedral's organ is on a big stone balcony that rises above the main floor. To get there, we went through a wooden door and up twisting stone stairs with uneven grooves that have worn in over the centuries. At the top, Clauzade and I were in a stone area lit by the moonlight coming in from a gigantic ornate window.
是需要持续很长时间的演出的完美乐器。大教堂的管风琴位于主楼上方的一个大石制阳台上。为了到达那里，我们穿过一扇木门，沿着蜿蜒的石头楼梯向上走，楼梯上有几个世纪以来磨损出的不平整凹槽。在顶部，克劳斯·阿德和我来到一个石制区域，这里被从一扇巨大的华丽窗户透进来的月光照亮。
Oh wow. We're inside the organ here. Impressive sight. You can look down there. This was my first time being inside a working pipe organ, and my first thought was that the name organ fits. Like a bodily organ, a pipe organ is an intricate system. And this system is all about moving air. And only air. Which is also the reason an organ can play much, much longer notes than a piano. Its sound doesn't come from a vibrating string. It comes from airflow. The air is drawn from whatever space the organ happens to be in. In this case, it came from inside the cathedral itself.
哦，哇。我们现在在管风琴内部了。真是令人印象深刻的景象。你可以往下看。这是我第一次进入一个运转中的管风琴内部，我的第一个想法是“管风琴（organ）”这个名字真贴切。就像身体的器官一样，管风琴是一个复杂的系统。而这个系统完全是为了输送空气。而且只有空气。这也是管风琴能够奏出比钢琴长得多、多得多的音符的原因。它的声音不是来自振动的琴弦。它来自气流。空气是从管风琴碰巧所在的任何空间中抽取进来的。在这个例子中，它来自大教堂内部本身。
Klaus Erhard showed me an opening with a screen over it. That's to prevent birds from going in and not coming out again. Sometimes they let them fall and then they are inside and they die. From the cathedral's interior, the air goes into the organ through the bellows. These are basically big pumps. In the old days, bellows had to be manually pushed, sometimes by people standing on them and working them like a big medieval stair master. But in modern organs, like the one I was climbing around in, the process
克劳斯·埃尔哈德向我展示了一个带网罩的开口。那是为了防止鸟类飞进去却出不来。有时候它们会掉下去，然后在里面死掉。从大教堂内部，空气通过风箱进入管风琴。这些基本上是大泵。在过去，风箱必须手动推动，有时需要人们站在上面，像踩大型中世纪登阶机一样操作它们。但在现代管风琴中，就像我正在攀爬的这台，这个过程
has been electrified. Klaus Erhardt went over to turn on a switch. Is that snow? I don't think so. They're rising. Yeah. From the bellows, we passed through another door into a room full of pipes standing in orderly rows. Then we went up a series of increasingly narrow ladders and stairs, climbing higher and higher into more rooms with more pipes. Some were wider than a bowling ball, while others were barely bigger than a pencil. The way the air from the bellows becomes music is by passing through these pipes. Every pipe
已经电动化了。克劳斯·埃尔哈德走过去打开了一个开关。那是雪吗？我想不是。它们在上升。是的。从风箱出来后，我们穿过另一门，进入一个摆满整齐排列的管子的房间。然后我们顺着一系列越来越窄的梯子和楼梯向上爬，越爬越高，进入更多摆着更多管子的房间。有些管子比保龄球还粗，而另一些则几乎比铅笔大不了多少。风箱里的空气变成音乐的方式是通过这些管子。每一根管子
is tuned to a note, A, Bb, C sharp, and so on. But each pipe also has its own voice based on how it's made. It could be big and brassy, or thin and reedy. An organist decides which voices to use by opening or closing what are called stops. If the stop for the big brassy pipes is open, that's what the organ will sound like. And an organist doesn't need to choose only one stop. Multiple stops can be open all at once, so a single press of a key sends air through multiple pipes. This is where we get the phrase pulling out all the stops. I asked Klaus Ad if he could pull out all the stops for a single key.
都被调到一个音符，A、降B、升C，等等。但每根管子也根据其制造方式拥有自己的音色。它可以很大声且具有铜管乐器的音色，也可以纤细而带有芦苇般的音色。管风琴演奏者通过打开或关闭被称为“音栓”的装置来决定使用哪些音色。如果大型铜管管子对应的音栓是打开的，管风琴就会发出那种声音。而且管风琴演奏者不需要只选择一个音栓。多个音栓可以同时打开，因此只需按一下琴键，气流就会穿过多个管子。这就是我们常说的“全力以赴（pulling out all the stops，原意为拉开所有音栓）”这个短语的由来。我问克劳斯·阿德他是否可以为一个音符拉开所有音栓。
Can you just walk me through one note as the stops open and what the sound is? Well, one stop after the other. Yeah, add each one. For instance, we're here. Or also different. And so different. And so on. And for instance I can couple. That's amazing. As long as there's an open stop, a pressed key, and a flow of air, an organ can play a note like this indefinitely.
你能带我过一遍单个音符在音栓打开时的声音变化吗？嗯，一个音栓接着一个音栓。对，每一个都加上。比如，我们在这儿。或者也可以不同。如此不同。诸如此类。比如我可以进行联动。太棒了。只要有一个打开的音栓、一个被按下的琴键以及持续的气流，管风琴就可以无限期地弹奏这样一个音符。
So back in 1987, when Cage rewrote ASLSP specifically for the organ, his instruction to play it as slow as possible took on a whole new meaning. Cage died in 1992, but six years later, musicologists and philosophers met at a conference in Germany to determine what was the best way to play ASLSP really slowly on an organ, and how long could you possibly play it for? And they made something in Germany we called Brainstorm. Reiner Neugebauer is the chair of the board of trustees for the John Cage Organ Project.
所以在 1987 年，当凯奇专门为管风琴重写《ASLSP》时，他将其尽可能慢地演奏的指示赋予了全新的含义。凯奇于 1992 年逝世，但六年后的德国的一场会议上，音乐学家和哲学家们聚在一起，探讨在管风琴上真正缓慢演奏《ASLSP》的最佳方式是什么，以及你究竟能把它演奏多久？他们在德国创造了一个我们称之为“头脑风暴”的东西。赖纳·诺伊格鲍尔是约翰·凯奇管风琴项目理事会的主席。
He says the conference attendees had some very different opinions, like whether the organist playing ASLSP could or should stay at the organ. And one said, oh, the organist must go to the loo or eat something. Then one religious or theologian people say, no, no, the organist must play until he die, fell dead from the seat. So it was a lifetime of the organist.
他说，与会者有非常不同的意见，比如演奏《ASLSP》的管风琴演奏者是否可以或应该一直呆在管风琴旁。其中一人说，哦，管风琴演奏者必须去上厕所或吃点东西。然后一位宗教或神学界人士说，不，不，管风琴演奏者必须一直演奏到死，从座位上倒地身亡。所以这是演奏者的一生。
Reiner says these ideas weren't quite right, because an organist can only play a piece for so long. But the music doesn't say a person has to be the one playing it. You need not all the time an organist. You can fix the keys. In other words, you could find a way to keep the keys depressed so there's always a flow of air. No organist needed. With this approach, the only theoretical limit would be the lifespan of the organ itself.
赖纳说这些想法并不完全正确，因为演奏者只能把一首曲子演奏一段时间。但乐谱并没有说必须由一个人来演奏它。你不需要一直都有演奏者。你可以把琴键固定住。换句话说，你可以找到一种方法让琴键保持下压状态，这样就会一直有气流通过。不需要演奏者。用这种方法，唯一的理论极限就是管风琴本身的寿命。
So when the organ breaks down, the music is over. Out of this debate came an idea to play a very long rendition of Organ 2 ASLSP on an organ made specifically for the performance. The philosophers, theologians, and musicologists also needed a place to host this indefinite concert and they landed on Halberstadt. Halberstadt was, in many ways, the perfect choice. Because it might not seem like it, but in the world of pipe organs, this rural German town of 40,000 people is kind of a big deal.
所以当管风琴损坏时，音乐就结束了。这场辩论产生了一个想法：在专门为这次演出制作的管风琴上，对《管风琴 2/ASLSP》进行一次超长时间的演绎。哲学家、神学家和音乐学家们还需要一个地方来举办这场无限期的音乐会，最终他们选中了哈尔贝施塔特。在许多方面，哈尔贝施塔特都是完美的选址。因为你可能看不出来，但在管风琴的世界里，这个拥有 4 万人口的德国乡村小镇相当有名。
In restaurants and hotels, I kept seeing brochures that call Halberstadt, Orgelstadt, Oregon City. On the back, there was a map to eight different pipe organs around town. That's roughly one pipe organ for every 5,000 people. And the project's organizers knew about an old church in a nun's cloister called St. Bucardi that would be perfect for the performance. By 1998, the church wasn't in good shape. It had been used for just about everything but religious services since the early 19th century.
在餐馆和酒店里，我总能看到称哈尔贝施塔特为“Orgelstadt（管风琴之城）”的小册子。背面有一张标有城中八个不同管风琴的地图。这大约相当于每 5,000 人就拥有一台管风琴。项目组织者知道修女修道院里有一座名为圣布尔卡迪的古老教堂，非常适合这场演出。到 1998 年时，这座教堂的情况已经不容乐观了。自 19 世纪初以来，除了宗教仪式，它几乎被用作过各种用途。
It was storage, a brewery, a barn for pigs. The city agreed to hand over the church to the project, but the performance was far from ready. We had the location and then we had to think about how long do we play. Anneli Borgman is another member of the board of the Cage Project, along with Klaus Aert and Heinrich, and she says that figuring out how long to play isn't as easy as saying, play until the organ falls apart. ASLSP is written as sheet music. It has a beginning and an end.
它被当过仓库、啤酒厂、养猪的牲口棚。市政府同意将教堂交给这个项目，但演出还远没有准备好。我们有了场地，然后我们必须考虑我们要演奏多久。安娜丽·博格曼是凯奇项目理事会的另一位成员，与克劳斯·阿德·海因里希并列，她说弄清楚演奏多久并不像说“演奏到管风琴散架为止”那么简单。《ASLSP》是作为乐谱写出来的。它有开始也有结束。
You have to have some kind of tempo if you're actually going to play it. So the foundation looked back into Halberstadt's history with organs. We have so many churches, and of course, so many organs, and also organ history. That history had begun in the 14th century and of course so many organs, and also organ history. That history had begun in the 14th century
如果你真的要演奏它，你必须有一定的节奏。因此，基金会回顾了哈尔贝施塔特与管风琴的历史。我们有这么多的教堂，当然还有这么多的管风琴，以及管风琴的历史。那段历史始于 14 世纪，当然还有这么多的管风琴，以及管风琴的历史。那段历史始于 14 世纪
with the installation of an organ in the town cathedral. And so someone suggested, hey, exactly how long ago did the town's cathedral get its old organ? Let's play the piece for that long. Which came out to 639 years. And so on John Cage's birthday, September 5th, 2001, Reiner and the other members of the Foundation
通过在城镇大教堂安装管风琴而开始。于是有人建议，嘿，这座城镇的大教堂得到它的旧管风琴究竟是多久以前的事？我们就把这首曲子演奏那么长时间。算下来刚好是 639 年。所以在约翰·凯奇的生日，2001 年 9 月 5 日，赖纳和基金会的其他成员
gathered in St. Bucardi and began their 639-year journey. With a rest. At the beginning, there were just the bellows because the piece starts with a break. And so you just heard for 17 months, just the bellows because the peace starts with a break. And so you just heard for 17 months just the bellows. The bellows for the cage organ are in the back of the church, in a wood structure about the size of a small car.
聚集在圣布尔卡迪教堂，开始了他们为期 639 年的旅程。以一个休止符开始。一开始，只有风箱在响，因为这首曲子是以一个间歇开始的。所以你听了整整 17 个月，都只有风箱的声音，因为这曲子以间歇开场。所以你听了整整 17 个月，只有风箱的声音。凯奇管风琴的风箱在教堂后面，在一个大约一辆小汽车大小的木制结构里。
They have a backup motor that keeps them going, and they haven't ever stopped pumping air, even if that air doesn't go through any pipes and just vents out into the church. After that first day, if you went to see the performance, that's what you'd hear, just the sound of air moving through this contraption. You could say this was the soft-morning city Lisp referenced in the piece's title. It was all very Cajun. The organ's design was similarly notable for what's not there. There's no piano-style keyboard or switches
它们有一个备用马达让它们运转，而且它们从未停止过泵送空气，即使这些空气没有穿过任何管道，只是排泄到教堂里。在第一天之后，如果你去看演出，这就是你会听到的声音——只有空气穿过这个奇特装置的声音。你可以说这就是这首作品标题中提到的“温柔的清晨之城口齿不清”。这一切都非常“凯奇”。管风琴的设计同样因其“没有的东西”而引人注目。这里没有钢琴式的键盘或开关
to open or close stops. The only controls are three small wooden keys on the front with tiny sandbags holding them down to keep the air moving through the pipes, which sit in a spare wooden frame. To make different notes, the foundation members replace the pipes, putting sit in a spare wooden frame. To make different notes, the foundation members replace the pipes, putting new ones into open slots and taking old ones out.
来打开或关闭音栓。唯一的控制装置是前面的三个小木键，上面有小沙袋压着，以保持空气流过位于简陋木架子中的管子。为了发出不同的音符，基金会成员会更换管子，把新的放入开放的槽中，把旧的拿出来。
Certain upcoming sections of the composition may require more pipes than the organ can currently fit, but because this is as slow as possible, Annalee Borgman says the question isn't urgent. This is the question of people after us, because the first part is ending in 2072. So I am 100 years old then. And I think they will, I don't know, perhaps in 2060, they will discuss how to go further on. And it won't be the first time the piece has needed some adjustments. You might think that with only one note
作品接下来的某些部分可能需要比管风琴目前能容纳的更多的管子，但因为这是尽可能慢的演奏，安娜丽·博格曼说这个问题并不急迫。这是我们身后的人的问题，因为第一部分将在 2072 年结束。所以我那时就 100 岁了。我想他们会，我不知道，也许在 2060 年，他们会讨论如何进一步推进。而且这不会是这首曲子第一次需要做一些调整。你可能会想，只有一个音符
to play every couple of years, what could possibly go wrong? Well, it turns out a lot. The first chord change was on the wrong date. Early on, a reporter did some calculations and realized the project had gotten the math wrong. He told Reiner that the 17 months of Bellows blasting at the beginning should have been
每隔几年才演奏一次，究竟能出什么差错？嗯，事实证明差错可多啦。第一次和弦转换日期搞错了。早期，一位记者做了一些计算，意识到该项目把数学算错了。他告诉赖纳，开头的 17 个月风箱轰鸣
28 months if the piece was to truly last until 2640. The slowest possible performance was moving too fast. So now where can we catch the 11 months? Because we are Germans. And Germans had the idea when I made a work and when I end a work, it must be correct." The group postponed the next chord change to make up the time, and now the piece is back on schedule. But that wasn't the only problem when the project got going. The first chord to play after the 17 months of rest
如果这首作品真的要持续到 2640 年，应该延长到 28 个月。最慢可能的演奏速度其实太快了。所以现在我们在哪里可以把这 11 个月补回来？因为我们是德国人。而德国人有这样的想法：当我制作一件作品并结束一件作品时，它必须是正确的。为了补回时间，该小组成员将下一次和弦转换推迟了，现在这首曲子又回到了正轨上。但当项目启动时，这并不是唯一的问题。17 个月休止后要演奏的第一个和弦
was also too loud. And it was a very disharmonic tone. And it's, oh, what, what, what's, when you broke, oh, when the, when the car was broken, broken. Oh, car, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, so it sounded a little bit like this. And there was people who heard it and they go to the police and said, Yeah, yeah, so it sounded a little bit like this. And there was people who heard it and they go to the police and say, we can't sleep.
声音也太大了。而且这是一个非常不和谐的音调。这，哦，什么，什么，什么，当，哦，当汽车坏了，坏了。哦，车，是啊，是啊。对，对，所以听起来有点像这样。有听到的人去报警说：对，对，所以听起来有点像这样。有听到的人去报警说，我们没法睡觉。
But you can't just turn a pipe organ down. The sound comes from air moving through pipes. There's no volume knob. So for almost 10 years, they had to put the organ underneath an ugly plexiglass box, which warped the sound. Then, in 2011, they brought in two new bass pipes. The new pipes, plus some adjustments to the bellows, made the organ quieter. Two neighbors I spoke with, Jakim and Margit Trube, say that today they can't hear the organ at all.
但你不能把管风琴的声音调小。声音来自穿过管子的气流。这里没有音量旋钮。所以在将近 10 年的时间里，他们不得不把管风琴放在一个丑陋的有机玻璃箱下面，这扭曲了声音。然后，在 2011 年，他们引入了两根新的低音管。新管子加上对风箱的一些调整，使管风琴变得安静了。我交谈过的两位邻居，雅基姆和玛吉特·特鲁布说，如今他们根本听不到管风琴的声音了。
It's too quiet. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No, no, you can't hear that. I asked what they think of it, and Joachim said it doesn't really have a deep meaning to him. You have to be an artist or a music lover to understand it, he said. Which I guess he was not. No. No. No. But one thing Joachim does notice is that the organ brings in tourists.
太安静了。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不. 不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不. 不，不，你听不到那个。我问他们对它的看法，雅基姆说这对他来说其实没有什么深意。他说，你必须是一个艺术家或音乐爱好者才能理解它。我想他大概不是吧。不。不。不。但雅基姆确实注意到的一件事是，管风琴带来了游客。
The project is good, he says. The project is good. The morning of the court change, the Cloisters courtyard filled up a few hours before the big event. Uta Persie was sitting next to the church, sheltering from the wind. She'd come from Hamburg.
他说，这个项目很好。这个项目很好。和弦转换的那天早晨，在重大活动开始前几个小时，修道院的庭院就挤满了人。乌塔·佩尔西坐在教堂旁边，躲避着风。她是从汉堡赶来的。
You're out in the cold, in the wind, waiting to get in? I got my coffee here, no problem. She was pretty dedicated. I take a day off holidays. You're on vacation? You took holiday from work? Yes. Some people made even more of a trip out of the chord change,
你顶着风寒在外面排队等候进去吗？我带了咖啡，没问题。她非常执着。我请了一天假。你在休假吗？你请了假不工作？是的。有些人为了这场和弦转换甚至进行了更远途的旅行，
even if they didn't know much about experimental music. Like Albert Schia and Peter Z, who were on their first trip to Europe. Well, I came here from Victoria, BC. Wow. I'm from New York. And you flew in just for this? came here from Victoria, BC. Wow. Yeah. I'm from New York. And you flew in just for this?
即使他们对实验音乐并不了解多少。比如阿尔伯特·希亚和彼得·Z，他们是第一次来欧洲旅行。嗯，我是从BC省维多利亚过来的。哇。我来自纽约。你们是专门为这个飞过来的吗？从BC省维多利亚过来的。哇。是的。我来自纽约。你们是专门为这个飞过来的吗？
Yeah. Kind of, yeah. That's a good excuse to, you know, come to Europe, but... It's the highlight. Yeah, it's the highlight. Are you big Cage fans? We have never heard anything about Cage. About 500 people showed up, and as the change approached, the church doors opened.
对。算是吧。这是来欧洲的一个好借口，但是……这是重头戏。对，这是重头戏。你们是凯奇的超级粉丝吗？我们以前从来没听说过凯奇。大约有 500 人到场，随着转换时刻的临近，教堂大门打开了。
We packed inside the church, which was quite cold. Reiner and a few others walked in and gathered in front of the organ, next to a music stand displaying the score, with lines marking each month of the performance. Another board member began to speak. As the audience settled in, the speaker asked for a few minutes of silence. The next five minutes, we will few minutes of silence.
我们挤进教堂里面，里面相当冷。赖纳和其他几个人走了进去，聚集在管风琴前面，旁边是一个展示着乐谱的谱架，上面有标明每场演出月份的线条。另一位理事会成员开始发言。当观众们安顿下来后，发言者要求大家默哀几分钟。接下来的五分钟，我们将默哀几分钟。
It was eerie. I was surrounded by hundreds of people, no one making a sound, as we just listened to the unchanging drone. Then, wearing white gloves, Reiner approached the organ carrying a new pipe, tuned to D natural. As he lowered it into an opening in the organ, we could hear the air start to move, and the entire organ adjust to the change. We stayed still for two more minutes, all of us surrounded by this new sound. — You're welcome. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you.
这太诡异了。我被数百人包围着，没有一个人发出声音，我们只是静静地听着那永恒不变的持续音。接着，戴着白手套的赖纳拿着一支调到 D 本位音的新管子走向管风琴。当他把它放入管风琴的一个开口时，我们听到空气开始流动，整个管风琴都在为这一改变做出调整。我们又静止了两分钟，所有人都被这种新声音环绕着。—— 不客气。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。
— Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you.
—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。
— Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. — Thank you. to someone crying, it was Aletta Jekker with the Cage Project. She had handed Reiner the new pipe. My role was only to bring him the organ pipe so he could put it in. That was my part. How did it feel? Crazy. It was so emotional. It's only an organ pipe, but it's quite emotional actually. What gives it such weight? You know, you listen to this for about two years, and now you say goodbye to a sound.
—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。—— 谢谢。伴随着哭泣声，那是凯奇项目的阿莱塔·耶克尔。她把新管子递给了赖纳。我的角色只是把管风琴管带给他，以便他能把它放进去。这就是我的部分。感觉怎么样？太疯狂了。太情绪化了。这虽然只是一根管风琴管，但实际上相当感人。是什么赋予了它如此厚重的分量？你知道的，你听这个听了大约两年，现在你要对一个声音说再见了。
Outside, it was kind of like a music festival. People were hanging out, sitting on the grass, and some were making plans to come for the next chord change, including Ettore Bartolini. And what did you think? No thoughts. No impression or anything? I think the matter is quite self-evident.
外面有点像个音乐节。人们闲逛着，坐在草地上，有些人甚至在计划为下一次和弦转换再来，其中包括埃托雷·巴尔托利尼。你觉得怎么样？没什么想法。没有什么感想之类的吗？我觉得这件事本身就很不言自明。
I met some scouts who had a tradition of hiking to Halberstadt for chord changes. Another group was making a documentary about the project that won't be done until the organ concert ends. They plan to pass the unfinished work from generation to generation for centuries. But even for the most devoted, there's only so much time you can spend with the organ. Reiner Neugebauer is 70. He's spent almost a third of his life with the concert. And he says it takes a lot of busy, frantic, not slow as possible activity
我遇到了一些童军，他们有一个徒步去哈尔贝施塔特看和弦转换的传统。另一个小组正在拍摄一部关于这个项目的纪录片，直到管风琴音乐会结束才会拍完。他们计划将这个未完成的工作世世代代地传承下去，长达数百年。但即使是对最狂热的粉丝来说，你能和管风琴共度的时间也是有限的。赖纳·诺伊格鲍尔已经 70 岁了。他将生命中近三分之一的时间都花在了这场音乐会上。他说，要让“尽可能慢”继续下去，需要做大量忙碌、狂热、一点也不慢的活动
to keep as slow as possible going. Between giving tours, managing volunteers, raising money, promoting the performance, and just checking in on the organ, organ 2 ASLSP is actually a lot of work. Now, Reiner is thinking of stepping back, which to him means embracing the uncertainty of the project. Do you think it'll make it all 639 years? This is a very hard question. You must say we don't know it. Maybe in 500 years it's too hot here that no more people live here.
介于进行导览、管理志愿者、筹集资金、宣传演出以及仅仅是查看管风琴的情况之间，《管风琴 2/ASLSP》实际上是一项非常繁重的工作。现在，赖纳正在考虑退居二线，对他而言，这意味着拥抱这个项目的不确定性。你认为它能坚持完这整整 639 年吗？这是一个非常难的问题。你必须说我们不知道。也许在 500 年后这里太热了，以至于再也没有人住在这里了。
In the last 20 years, we have four times big holes in the roof from heavy storms. Maybe one of the dictators who have the nuclear power smash atom bomb. Maybe there are no people who are interested in it. I don't know. This is a serious answer. Currently, the biggest threat is funding. It costs about 60,000 euros a year to run the organ, plus all the hours of volunteers. There are plaques along the wall of the church where people have sponsored years of the performance,
在过去的 20 年里，我们因特大风暴屋顶上破了四次大洞。也许某个拥有核力量的独裁者会投下原子弹。也许没有人对它感兴趣。我不知道。这是一个严肃的回答。目前，最大的威胁是资金。运营这台管风琴每年大约需要 6 万欧元，再加上无数志愿者的工时。教堂的墙壁上挂着铭牌，人们在那里赞助了演出的一年又一年，
and the foundation is planning to pre-sell tickets to the final performance, which will be passed down to future generations. The cost? 2,640 euros, as in the year the concert will end. And there are plans to host events and other projects at the Cloister to generate not only revenue, but more volunteers who will keep this going. One of those volunteers is Annalee Borgman, who joined the project four years ago. She's planning to get even more involved in the coming decades.
基金会正计划预售最后一场演出的门票，这些门票将传给后代。费用是多少？2,640 欧元，正如音乐会结束的年份。并且他们计划在修道院举办活动和其他项目，不仅为了创造收入，还为了招募更多能让这项工作持续下去的志愿者。其中一位志愿者是安娜丽·博格曼，她在四年前加入了这个项目。她正计划在未来的几十年里更多地参与其中。
But it will get a really busy year. In 2034, we will have three chord changes, so we have really a hectic period then. Yeah, it'll be moving pretty fast at that point. Do you find humor in the project as well? Of course. I think it's really okay if somebody thinks that's a joke. For every person it's a different project. For me it's a serious project, but I can also smile about it. For example, I get a smile when I'm in the church.
但这将是非常忙碌的一年。2034 年，我们将迎来三次和弦转换，所以到时候我们真的会有一个相当忙乱的时期。是的，到那个时候它的进展会相当快。你也会在这个项目中找到幽默感吗？当然。我觉得如果有人认为这是个笑话，那真的没关系。对每个人来说，这是一个不同的项目。对我来说，这是一个严肃的项目，但我也能对它付诸一笑。例如，当我在教堂里时，我会忍不住微笑。
For example, a bird is coming in the church. It's wonderful and it's also funny. And I kid you not, the Germans have a word for that feeling. In German you say verrückt, a crazy idea. And in German there's a double meaning. On one hand it's crazy and on the other hand it's moved. Moved. As in, to move something to the side. To set it off. To follow its own beat.
比如，一只鸟飞进了教堂。这既美妙又搞笑。我没骗你，德国人对这种感觉有一个专门的词。在德语里你叫它 verrückt，一个疯狂的想法。在德语里它有双重含义。一方面是疯狂，另一方面是感动。感动。就像把某物移到旁边。把它搁置一旁。遵循它自己的节奏。
Even if that beat is extremely slow. After three days in Halberstadt, I went back to see the organ alone. All the earlier excitement around the chord change had been just a blip in the life of the performance. Now, as it is most of the time, the organ was just in the church by itself, with no crowds, no TV cameras, no tourists. I walked around the church, listening to the ways the pipes interact with each other and with the walls and floor. How the performance changed as I moved. It was more discordant in some places, more like one even tone in others. I went to the corner where Reiner recommended I stand. There's this open space here. The sound is really, you can hear
即使这个节奏极其缓慢。在哈尔贝施塔特待了三天后，我一个人回去看管风琴。围绕着和弦转换的所有早期兴奋感，在演出的生命周期中不过是一个小插曲。现在，和大多数时候一样，管风琴独自在教堂里，没有人群，没有电视摄像机，没有游客。我在教堂里走来走去，聆听管子之间、以及它们与墙壁和地板相互作用的方式。当我移动时，演出是如何变化的。在某些地方它更不和谐，而在其他地方更像是一个均匀的单一音调。我走到赖纳建议我站立的角落。这里有一个开放的空间。声音真的很……你能听到
different overtones coming through. It doesn't sound especially like it's coming from the organ. It seems like it's almost coming out of the walls. I started to feel almost giddy, overwhelmed not just by the sound, but by the idea of the project going on for centuries in this same place. If all goes according to plan, it'll play long after I'm dead. It was haunting and unsettling, but then kind of peaceful. Then it was funny again. Verrückt. I'm looking at an organ playing a chord for two and a half years out of 639 years. for two and a half years out of 639 years. What am I doing here?
不同的泛音穿透过来。它听起来特别不像来自管风琴。它几乎像是从墙壁里发出来的。我开始感到有些眩晕，不仅仅是被声音压倒，而是被这个项目将在同一个地方持续数个世纪的想法所震撼。如果一切按计划进行，它在我死后很久仍会演奏。这既迷人又让人不安，但随后又有一种平静感。然后它又变得滑稽了。Verrückt。我正在看着一个管风琴在 639 年里用两年半的时间演奏一个和弦。在 639 年里用两年半的时间演奏一个和弦。我在这里做什么？
I don't know. I like knowing that it's here. Later, I thought back to that old archival interview with John Cage. When I talk about music, it finally comes to people's minds that I'm talking about sound that doesn't mean anything. And they say, you mean it's just sounds? Thinking that for something to just be a sound is to be useless. Whereas I love sounds just as they are. And I have no need for them to be anything more.
我不知道。我喜欢知道它就在这里。后来，我回想起当年对约翰·凯奇的那次旧档案采访。当我谈论音乐时，人们最终会想到我谈论的是没有任何意义的声音。他们说，你的意思是这只是声音？认为某种东西仅仅是声音就是毫无用处的。而我热爱声音原本的样子。我不需要它们有任何更多的意义。
I just want it to be a sound. Music When we come back, we'll explore a different contribution Halberstadt has made to music history 663 years in the past. Stick around. So we're back with Gabe Bullard. And Gabe, you mentioned in the story that Halberstadt got a pipe organ in 1361, and apparently that organ has a more significant role in music history than just inspiring this very, very long organ concert. Yeah. So the records from the 14th century aren't exactly great, but historians have reason to think
我只希望它是一个声音。音乐 稍后回来，我们将探索哈尔贝施塔特在过去 663 年里对音乐史做出的另一项贡献。不要走开。我们欢迎加布·布拉德回归。加布，你在故事中提到哈尔贝施塔特在 1361 年就拥有了一台管风琴，显然这台管风琴在音乐史上的作用不仅仅是启发了这场极其漫长的管风琴音乐会。是的。所以 14 世纪的记录并不是很准确，但历史学家有理由认为
that Halberstadt's organ played an important role in the creation of the standard Western piano keyboard that we're so familiar with today. Okay, interesting. Tell me a little bit more. I will, but first I wanna give you a sense of what pipe organs in the 14th century were like, because they were played a little differently
哈尔贝施塔特的管风琴在现代人如此熟悉的标准西方钢琴键盘的诞生过程中发挥了重要作用。好的，很有意思。多跟我讲讲。好的，但首先我想让你了解一下 14 世纪的管风琴是什么样的，因为它们的演奏方式
from the modern pipe organ. When I talked to Klaus Errd Heinrich, the music director at the Halberstadt Cathedral, he told me some of the old organs were really hard to play. And apologies because in this clip you'll see Claus-Erd's English and my German didn't quite meet in the middle. Okay, um, muddle through. You couldn't play fast. It was very heavy. What were they doing? How were they playing the original? You had to, in Latin, tractare,
与现代管风琴略有不同。当我采访哈尔贝施塔特大教堂音乐总监克劳斯·埃尔哈德·海因里希时，他告诉我一些旧管风琴真的很难弹。抱歉，在这个片段中你会发现克劳斯·埃尔哈德的英语和我的德语并没有完全契合。好的，呃，凑合着听吧。你不能弹得很快。它非常重。他们在做什么？他们是怎么弹奏原版的？你必须，用拉丁语来说，tractare，
to beat the horn, but it was very heavy. What was it that people were hitting? It wasn't like a key. No, it was, so a key. No, it was a bowl. A bowl. It was made of wood. Oh, like a hole? If you eat something, you have...
去敲打号角，但它非常重。人们敲击的到底是什么？它不像是琴键。不，它是一个，一个琴键。不，它是一个碗。一个碗。它是木制的。哦，就像一个洞？如果你吃东西，你有……
Oh, a plate? Something like that. A very great spoon. You have... Oh, a plate? Yeah, something like... Or a spoon or a bowl? Yeah, no, no, yeah. A very great spoon. Okay, okay. A very good spoon. And you could beat with a fist. And so to translate what Klaus Herd meant by a very great spoon was basically a bowl.
哦，一个盘子？类似的东西。一把非常大的勺子。你有……哦，一个盘子？对，类似于……或者一把勺子或一个碗？对，不，不，是的。一把非常大的勺子。好的，好的。一把非常好的勺子。你可以用拳头敲打。为了翻译克劳斯·埃尔哈德所说的“非常大的勺子”是什么意思，基本上就是一个碗。
Okay, so if I'm understanding correctly, instead of keys, as we know them, there were like these hand-sized bowls that people hit down with their fists. Yeah, yeah, like they would hit them down and hold them down with their whole hand. I mean, given that limitation and the sort of strength to play the organ, I'm amazed organs caught on at all. Yeah, me too. But the big thing with these early organs is that whatever size the keys
好的，如果我没理解错的话，代替我们所知的琴键的，是那些人们用拳头向下敲击的手掌大小的碗？是的，是的，就像他们会把它们敲下去，并用整个手掌按住它们一样。我的意思是，考虑到这种局限性和弹奏管风琴所需的体力，我很惊讶管风琴居然能流行起来。是的，我也是。但这些早期管风琴的关键在于，无论琴键的尺寸如何
were, they weren't laid out the same from organ to organ. How so? So if you picture what you would see today when you sit down at almost any piano or organ or synthesizer, you're almost certainly seeing your standard 12 keys. Seven white, five black. And that represents an octave. Right, and so when we talk about going up or down an octave, we're talking about doubling or halving the frequency of the sound. Like that part is just physics. That's always been true. And so the pattern of 12 keys representing one octave
它们在不同的管风琴上的布局并不相同。怎么说呢？如果你想象一下今天坐在几乎任何钢琴、管风琴或合成器前会看到什么，你几乎肯定会看到标准的 12 个键。七个白键，五个黑键。这就代表了一个八度。没错，所以当我们谈论上行或下行一个八度时，我们指的是音频频率的加倍或减半。这部分纯粹是物理学。这永远都是真的。因此，代表一个八度的 12 键模式
just repeats as your hands move to higher or lower octaves on the keyboard. Correct, and these 12 keys on the keyboard are even reflected in the way we write music, using a scale with 12 half steps. A, A sharp, B, C, C sharp, all the way back to A, a full octave higher. 12 keys playing 12 tones. But the thing is, it's not actually necessary to divide the octave into 12 tones like this. And for much of Western history, we didn't. So what were the other ways that you could divide up an octave?
当你把手移到键盘上更高或更低的八度时，只是在重复而已。没错，键盘上的这 12 个键甚至体现在我们写音乐的方式中，使用的是一个包含 12 个半音的音阶。A、升A、B、C、升C，一直回到高整整一个八度的 A。12 个键演奏 12 个音符。但问题是，实际上没必要把一个八度分成这样的 12 个音符。在西方历史的大部分时间里，我们也没有这样做。那么还有哪些其他方式可以划分八度呢？
12 was just one of many. An instrument could have fewer notes per octave. It could have more notes. It could have notes that didn't go up by a half step. There are centuries of mathematicians dividing up the octave differently. And just to give you two quick examples, here's something called the Ancient Greek Inharmonic Scale, which was likely developed somewhere around 600 BCE.
12 只是其中之一。一件乐器每个八度可以有更少的音符。它可以有更多的音符。它可以有不是按半音阶上升的音符。有几个世纪的数学家在用不同的方式划分八度。为了给你举两个简单的例子，这里有一种叫做古希腊增强音阶的东西，它可能是大约公元前 600 年左右在某个地方发展起来的。
And here's another ancient Greek scale. ["Symphony No. 5 in C-sharp"] Wow, and so what makes those scales sound so different? So with that first inharmonic scale, there are notes that are in between the notes on your standard piano keyboard. Like they would sit between the C and the C-sharp. And so your ear might not be used to them, but they've kind of been waiting around for us to listen to or to hear them for 2,500 years.
这里还有另一个古希腊音阶。[《升 C 小调第五交响曲》] 哇，是什么让这些音阶听起来如此不同？在第一个增强音阶中，有一些音符位于你标准钢琴键盘上的音符之间。就像它们会位于 C 和升 C 之间一样。所以你的耳朵可能不习惯它们，但它们在过去 2,500 年里一直等待着我们去倾听或聆听。
I mean, that's so cool. I love that, that 2,500 years ago, Western music could be built out of such different component parts and sounds so different from music of today. It's pretty cool. And that's how things were well through the Middle Ages. Musicians and instrument makers divided up the octaves using different scales.
我的意思是，这太酷了。我非常喜欢，在2500年前，西方音乐竟然可以由如此不同的组成部分构建出来，并且听起来和今天的音乐截然不同。这真的很酷。而且在中世纪的大部分时间里，情况一直如此。音乐家和乐器制作人使用不同的音阶来划分八度音阶。
But then in the year 1361, Halberstadt got its organ. Okay. I think I see where this is going. And I'm going to make you go there anyway, because I am now going to show you an old drawing that depicts what the keys on that first Halberstrasz organ looked like. Okay, so these are the really big and bulbous bowl paddles that you have to pound down with your fist.
但随后在1361年，哈尔伯施塔特迎来了它的管风琴。好吧。我想我大概知道这是怎么回事了。无论如何，我还是要让你去了解它，因为我现在要向你展示一幅古老的画作，它描绘了第一台哈尔伯施塔特管风琴上的琴键是什么样子的。好吧，这些是非常大且呈球状的碗形按键，你必须用拳头把它们砸下去。
But what's uncanny is that it really looks like a modern piano key layout. Like there's a big row of keys and smaller ones in between. You can totally see these are the white keys, these are the black keys. And for all intents and purposes, that looks like a present-day Western keyboard. Exactly, yeah, and it's believed this is the first example of a keyboard like this. Wow. And to be clear, records are very spotty. This
但不可思议的是，它看起来真的很像现代钢琴的琴键布局。就像有一排大琴键，中间夹着较小的琴键。你完全可以看出这些是白键，这些是黑键。不管怎么看，这看起来都像是一台现代的西方键盘。没错，是的，据信这是此类键盘的第一个例子。哇。需要说明的是，历史记录非常零散。这幅
drawing is from more than 200 years later, and while people had divided the octave into 12 notes before, this is what a lot of writers say was the first big church organ to organize the keys this way. And it played a big role in the layout becoming the standard in Western music as more and more instruments were built like this, with just 12 tones. Huh. And that's why almost all classical music is built around those 12 notes. Yeah. And one thing Klaus Ehred told me too is that there was this kind of push and pull between
画作来自200多年前，虽然之前人们曾将八度分成12个音符，但这幅画所描绘的正许多作家所说的第一座以这种方式排列琴键的大型教堂管风琴。随着越来越多的乐器以这种只有12个音调的方式建造，它在使这种布局成为西方音乐标准方面发挥了重要作用。嗯。这就是为什么几乎所有的古典音乐都是围绕这12个音符构建的。是的。克劳斯·埃雷德还告诉我的一点是，
organ makers and musicians. Composers could push the limits of what an organ could do, but unless organ makers changed their instruments, then the music had to fit what could physically be played. Right. And I suppose when you think about the most familiar music notation too, all the staffs, the sharps, the flat cymbals, they're indicating those 12 notes. Exactly.
管风琴制造商和音乐家之间存在一种拉锯战。作曲家可以突破管风琴功能的极限，但除非管风琴制造商改变他们的乐器，否则音乐就必须适应物理上能够弹奏出的效果。没错。我想，当你想到最熟悉的音乐记谱法时，所有的五线谱、升号、降号，它们都在指示那12个音符。完全正确。
Now, it should be said that there are some good underlying reasons why the 12-note system eventually became the dominant format. Dividing an octave by 12 makes harmonies and chords a lot easier to find and play. But on the other hand, the big downside is that the dominance of 12 notes ended up limiting the kind of music that could be made. Halberstadt's keyboard was saying that
现在必须指出的是，12音符系统最终成为主导格式是有一些很好的潜在原因的。将一个八度划分为12等分，使得和声和和弦更容易找到和演奏。但另一方面，主要的缺点是，12个音符的统治地位最终限制了可以创作的音乐类型。哈尔伯施塔特的键盘意味着
of all the notes inside an octave, you only have 12 to choose from. And so throughout the years, this has generated pushback. Yeah, I can imagine. So who pushed back and how did they push back? So that ancient Greek scale we heard earlier was from a 1958 documentary on the late music theorist and composer Harry Parch. And Parch was not a huge fan of the Halberstadt 12-tone limitation.
在一个八度音阶内的所有音符中，你只有12个可供选择。因此，这些年来，这引发了反弹。是的，我可以想象。那么，是谁进行了反弹，他们又是如何反弹的呢？所以我们之前听到的那个古希腊音阶来自一部1958年的纪录片，主角是已故的音乐理论家兼作曲家哈里·帕奇。而帕奇并不是哈尔伯施塔特12音限制的超级粉丝。
In a book in 1949, he coined a phrase that I heard a lot of people in Halberstadt say when I was reporting the story. The fatal day of Halberstadt. The fatal day of Halberstadt. Parch called it the fatal day of Halberstadt because it would eventually lead to that keyboard and then those tones being locked in for Western music
在1949年出版的一本书中，他创造了一个短语，我在做这个故事的报道时，在哈尔伯施塔特听到很多人说起过。哈尔伯施塔特灾难性的一天。哈尔伯施塔特灾难性的一天。帕奇称之为哈尔伯施塔特灾难性的一天，因为这最终会导致那个键盘的诞生，然后这些音调就被固定在西方音乐中，
and the other potential scales and tones kind of fading away. And Parch wanted to recover those old tones. And so what does that mean? Like, did he just want to resurrect other scales that had fallen out of disuse, like the ancient Greek one, or did he want to create entirely new scales? Both. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
而其他潜在的音阶和音调则逐渐消失。帕奇想要找回那些古老的音调。那么这到底是什么意思？我是说，他只是想复活那些已经废弃的其他音阶，比如古希腊的音阶，还是想创造全新的音阶？两者都是。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。
I like Harry Parch, okay. Yeah, he said we should question the ideas that physical instruments lock us into. So he built instruments that could play different intervals. And the math behind how to do this gets pretty strange, but he came up with a scale that had 43 notes. Here he is playing it on an instrument he made called a chromolodion.
我喜欢哈利·帕奇，好吧。是的，他说我们应该质疑那些将我们束缚住的实体乐器所带来的观念。所以他制造了能够演奏不同音程的乐器。这背后的数学原理变得非常奇怪，但他想出了一个包含43个音符的音阶。这是他在自己制作的一架名为铬琴的乐器上演奏它。
Here is the scale on my chromolodion and adapted reed organ. That makes me feel incredibly tense. Oh my goodness. Very parched. Okay, but up to this point, we've been focusing just on Western music and I've heard plenty music from different cultures where 12 tones isn't the standard and hasn't always been the standard. Oh definitely. A lot of Middle Eastern music uses up to 24 tones, and in a lot of places outside the influence
这是我的铬琴和改装簧风琴上的音阶。这让我感到非常紧张。哦天哪。非常帕奇。好吧，但到目前为止，我们一直只关注西方音乐，而我听过许多来自不同文化的音乐，在这些文化中，12个音调并不是标准，过去也并非标准。哦，当然。许多中东音乐使用多达24个音调，在许多不受
of the halberstad organ, scales and instruments have historically been played differently. And I should say, we hear these in-between tones, sometimes called microtones, all the time now, even in Western music. I'm looking at a guitar here in the corner of my office, all the time now, even in Western music. I'm looking at a guitar here in the corner of my office, and the neck has frets that divide the octave into 12 notes, but you can bend strings, and that can make the blue note that makes the blues so distinct. And sometimes a singer like Mariah Carey might do a big vocal run in a pop song.
哈尔伯施塔特管风琴影响的地方，音阶和乐器在历史上一直有着不同的演奏方式。我得说，我们现在随时都能听到这些处于中间的音符，有时被称为微音阶，甚至在西方音乐中也是如此。我正看着我办公室角落里的一把吉他，现在随时都能听到，甚至在西方音乐中也是如此。我正看着我办公室角落里的一把吉他，它的琴颈上有把八度音阶划分为12个音符的品丝，但你可以弯曲琴弦，这可以产生使布鲁斯音乐如此独特的布鲁斯音符。有时像玛丽亚·凯莉这样的歌手可能会在流行歌曲中进行大幅度的声乐演唱。
Or there's that opening bass slide in These Boots Are Made for Walkin'. Not everything fits that 12th note system, and people find ways around it. Well, Gabe, this has been so fascinating and fun. Thank you so much for sharing all this. Thank you, Roman. It's been a pleasure. 99% Ambizable was reported this week by Gay Bullard and edited by Joe Rosenberg with additional editing by Kelly Prime mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Sona Avakian, And special thanks this week to Linda Golden. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our
或者在《这些靴子是用来走路的》一曲中有那个开场的贝斯滑音。并非所有东西都符合那个第12音符系统，人们找到了绕过它的方法。好吧，盖比，这太迷人、太有趣了。非常感谢你分享这一切。谢谢你，罗曼。这真是我的荣幸。本周的《99%无形》由盖比·巴勒德报道，乔·罗斯伯格编辑，凯利·普莱姆协助编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·雷尔配乐，索娜·阿瓦基安核实事实，特别感谢本周的琳达·戈登。凯茜·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的
senior editor, Nikita Apte is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lash Madon, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Nina Potok, and me Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California.
高级编辑，尼基塔·阿普特是我们的实习生。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布、杰森·德莱昂、埃met·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉什·马顿、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、妮娜·波托克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99%无形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城区。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. And if you want to find out more about Hubbershot's CAGE project or its accompanying 639 year long documentary, there are links to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的新Discord服务器上找到我们。如果你想了解更多关于哈伯肖特CAGE项目或其长达639年的配套纪录片的信息，可以在99PI.org上找到相关的链接以及99PI过去的每一集节目。你这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。